everyone so now we will as a Janata Dal
man will tell us about algorithmic a
stability thank you very much thanks to
everyone for coming and thanks to the
organizers for inviting me
so what I'm gonna do in my talk is I
want to give sort of a high-level
overview of a number of works many of
which I am on some of which are actually
not not mine including some some work by
some people in this room such as Vitali
and and Moritz and Thomas and please
stop me for questions at any time so
fortunately Thomas will be speaking
after me on the same topic and we'll
dive into some of the more technical
content and so whatever I don't get to
he can just pick up where I left off so
okay so the basic set up so if I could
sort of you know horribly
mischaracterized statistics is that
typically there is a picture of Lee like
this where you start with some
hypothesis you collect some data and you
draw some conclusion and there's you
know an enormous literature on
statistical theory that gives you some
kind of guarantee that's if you've
collected enough data then whatever
conclusion you draw from the data set
will generalize to the population from
which the data was collected so this is
sort of the high level picture and yet
there seems to be some concern over
whether this picture really reflects
reality in radicular I think I got
interested in this topic many years ago
reading a and a famous paper called why
most published research findings are
false more recently there was an article
by Gillman and locum lokan called the
statistical crisis in science and if you
look at the kind of subtitle on this
paper it says data dependent analysis
which they call a Garden of forking
paths a reference to a short story by
bore case explains why many
statistically significant comparisons
don't hold up and what this data
dependent analysis refers to among other
things is that statistical practice
often has this feedback loop so once you
draw some conclusion about your data you
sort of use it to go back and formulate
some other hypothesis maybe some refined
of the hypothesis and then you often
evaluate this new hypothesis on the same
data and because the hypothesis and the
data are now related correlated through
this feedback loop the statistical
guarantees that we all know and love no
longer apply in this case so they don't
apply when this data set is kind of
reused interactively which is what I'm
referring to is interactive data
analysis it's sometimes called adaptive
data analysis that's another term you
may have seen so why would this come up
like what why why does this come up well
partly it just comes up because data is
finite so we don't want to collect a
data set for a single purpose we want to
reuse data sets but more specifically it
can come up in like a number of
different ways and it's useful to think
a little bit about what the different
types of interaction look like so the
first and maybe most like kind of
analytically friendly kind are sort of
well specified multistage procedures so
we're actually gonna see an example of
one in a little bit but a canonical
example to keep in mind is you collect
some data with you know some huge set of
features you look at this data and you
select some set of relevant features and
then using the same data set you train a
model you fit some model parameters to
those features and this is a common type
of thing one could try and many people
have analyzed these types of procedures
explicitly but there's also kind of
softer like fuzzier kinds of interactive
data analysis such as things like data
exploration or what Gulman and look and
I think referred to as researcher
degrees of freedom so these are just
ways in which the hypothesis you
formulate is influenced by the data
you've collected so one example is
something like say a data science
competition this is an example that
Moritz has studied and will see an
example of it and then there's just sort
of completely ill specified you know
some standard data set some sort of
benchmark data set persists it stays
around for a long time multiple research
groups reuse it and the problem here is
that because here the kind of choice of
hypothesis is made by an actual human or
some very complicated adaptive
algorithm maybe it's very hard to
analyze these explicitly so it's hard to
kind of remove the interaction by
treating these as a single process on a
data set so and we this is sort of the
the challenge that this line of work is
aimed at addressing is when it's hard to
analyze exactly what you're doing with
the data set as a result of complex
interaction so there are of course you
know many different approaches you could
take inspired by statistics so a common
one is say hypothesis testing or
multiple hypothesis testing these are
all essentially unsuitable because they
assume throughout that the hypotheses
you're testing are independent of the
data and it's not true in interactive
settings people often talk about
multiple hypothesis testing such as the
bonferroni correction or the Benjamin
Hochberg procedure which really are
addressing a different problem I'm not
going to say exactly too much about
those so for these kinds of well
specified algorithms there's a long and
very rich literature on kind of explicit
inference procedures that you know treat
this adaptive algorithm or this
interactive procedure is kind of one
algorithm and just analyze how it works
and this is tractable in some cases one
thing I would point out is that this is
often more of an analysis tool so it's
often about saying what inferences can
you draw in the presence of interaction
and less about how can you mitigate the
effects of interaction which is moreover
interested in and the last thing you can
do is you can always kind of reduce the
interactive case to the non interactive
case by just collecting more data so
either take your fixed data set and
split it up and use each piece of the
data once or you know every time you
want to go back to a data set you
collect more data but the problem here
is that the amount of data you need
grows linearly in the number of
interactive rounds so this is not very
it doesn't make a very efficient use of
data so what I want to talk about is
this kind of a new general approach to
interactive data analysis that tries to
avoid some of these barriers this comes
from kind of a pair of works including a
really beautiful paper by dirk Feldman
Hart Potosi Rheingold and Roth and also
in a paper of Moritz and myself and sort
of what we do is we introduce both some
kind of new general tools for addressing
this problem of interactive data
analysis and also kind of a
general methodology for how to think
about these problems and one thing I
like about this line of work is that we
actually get new algorithms for
preventing the sorts of overfitting that
can arise from interaction so it's not
merely analytic we also actually have
sort of algorithmic remedies for
mitigating the effects and the key
ingredient in these works are sort of
strong notions of algorithmic stability
so I'll talk a little bit about
algorithmic stability which comes up all
over the place and learning but a key
ingredient are kind of new notions of
algorithmic stability that were inspired
by something called differential privacy
inspired by ideas from the data privacy
literature and what you get out of these
notions of stability is that often you
can use randomized estimators to
actually improve the generalization
guarantees of your algorithms so this is
kind of a surprising way in which
privacy can actually help you achieve
good statistical properties and then
also briefly mention some new inherent
bottlenecks in these interactive
settings so both statistical and
computational bottlenecks that suggest
it may be hard to have a completely
satisfactory way of addressing these
problems in general which comes from
works with Moritz and also with with
Thomas so that's kind of the overview of
what I want to talk about and the first
thing I want to do is I want to give
sort of just an example of and of what I
mean by interaction and how it can lead
to very severe overfitting I'm gonna
give sort of a very specific setting so
so maybe unlike the kind of ill
specified settings that I talked about
in the intro but I think it just
highlights the the point and gives some
some perspective on what's going on so
here's a simple example of how
interaction can can go wrong so suppose
you have some population some
probability distribution of just
uniformly random labeled examples so I
have kind of an example space of plus
minus 1 to the D a label space of plus
minus 1 it's not so important the only
thing that's important is that I want to
think of this as very high dimensional
and what we're trying to do is we're
trying to learn some good classifier H
for mapping an example Y to a label Z
and we just want to maximize the
prediction quality so we want to you
know minimize the zero one loss or
maximize the correlation between the
hypothesis and the labels and a natural
thing to do of course would just be to
take your data set this these examples
and these labels and use the zero one
loss on the data set as a proxy for what
you're really after which is the zero
one loss on new samples from the
population you have a pretty standard
classification setup so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna describe like a
reasonable thing you might do that
involves interaction where you're going
to overfit very badly so this is
something called Friedman's paradox
essentially so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna consider each of the D features as
just an independent hypothesis so I'm
gonna start with some very naive idea
that maybe I could just use one of the
features to predict the labels and so
that gives me D hypotheses one for each
coordinate and here I've just sort of
drawn the label vector and here's sort
of a stand-in for the vector of
predicted labels from each of these
hypotheses and by assumption my data is
totally uniformly random so all these
vectors are random and independent and
so on average their correlation with Z
is zero but of course it's not really
zero sometimes it's you know plus one
over root n sometimes it's minus one
over root n it's gonna be somewhat away
from zero just due to random chance and
sometimes they'll have these blue
vectors that have positive correlation
and sometimes I'll have these orange
vectors that have negative correlation
so all I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
flip the signs of these hypotheses so
that they all have positive correlation
so now what I have is a bunch of kind of
independent classifiers each of which
has roughly positive 1 over root and
correlation with the label with the true
labels or the labels on my sample and
now I'll just take some like majority
vote of these so I have a bunch of
independent kind of weak classifiers and
I'll just take a majority vote and I
will get from that one hopefully pretty
good classifier and what you can show
essentially because each of the
individual class of
is correct on a different set of labels
what you can show is that the final
classifier I get will actually have
correlation that grows as about the
square root of D over N so if I have
more and more features I become very
likely to find some classifier that
predicts well for example if I have more
than n features I actually will find a
classifier that has essentially perfect
correlation with the labels on my data
set but of course this is all just pure
overfitting my data is uniformly random
so the labels are always completely
random on the on new samples no matter
what hypothesis I produced the true
score is going to be zero so what I've
done is I've managed to overfit very
badly so even though I only have looked
at a total of D plus one classifiers I
managed to produce correlation like
square root D over N and that's coming
from the fact that this final classifier
H star depends on the data right I know
which way to flip the signs I had to
look at the data and this sort of a toy
example admittedly although I will give
a plug for a paper by Blum and Hart and
a blog post that Moritz wrote about it
called competing in a data science
contest without reading the data in
which to a first approximation Moritz
showed that this is a really good way to
look like you're winning a data science
contest so I'll let you ask more it's
more about this but the punch line is
that he managed to sort of get six than
a data contest science contest just by
doing this but only retroactively Lee he
did not claim any money that he that he
told me about so how could we avoid this
trap so this as I said is a pretty like
well specified algorithm and so we could
just analyze this explicitly there there
are lots of ways to do that but let's
think a little more broadly about like
what went wrong so I want to take a
particular perspective on why I was able
to overfit to the data set so badly from
this interactive attack and the reason
is that what we did was we chose these D
hypotheses and then we saw their scores
on the data set X so we saw some
function of the data set X and the
function might seem not terribly
interesting it's just the score of some
classifier
but it turns out in some sense what this
attack actually shows is that these
scores reveal a lot of information about
the unknown vector of label Z so just
seeing the scores of these random
classifiers tells you a lot about the
labels in fact if D is bigger than M you
learn basically all the labels so they
reveal everything about the labels so
once you have this perspective of what
went wrong it's sort of obvious what to
do let's try to make sure that what you
learn from the first stage of the
analysis doesn't reveal too much
information about the labels or more
generally doesn't reveal too much
information about the data set you've
collected okay so that's just sort of
the opposite of what went wrong in the
attack and how would we do that
well we're gonna use ideas from
differential privacy so this is not
gonna be a privacy talk I feel like over
time I've sort of talked about privacy
less and less when I talk about this
line of work but the idea of how would
we give accurate scores on the data in a
way that doesn't reveal too much about
the data set itself uses techniques from
privacy that's sort of exactly the
problem you want to solve in in privacy
but the right perspective to have is
that algorithms that were designed in
the context of privacy actually have
very strong stability guarantees in a
sense that I'll make precise so first
let me talk a little bit about stability
it's like a word I've now used a bunch
of times and this is not news this has
been a central concept in learning
theory and statistics since the 70s
going back to the work of DeVry and
Wagner and a number of very nice works
throughout the years and there are a lot
of different stability notions it
depends a little bit on what problem
you're interested in but they all have
like roughly this kind of flavor they're
all what I call output stability
guarantees and what they basically say
is that if I have two data sets X and X
prime that are close to one another
maybe they differ on a small number of
samples then when I run some algorithm a
on those data sets the output of those
of the algorithm on the two data sets
should also be close in some
relevant metric okay so the metric will
of course depend on what the context is
but they all have this flavor that that
you have an algorithm that produces some
output and those outputs should be close
to one another in some sense and the
problem is that algorithm satisfying
this definition of stability can reveal
the data set entirely so this notion of
stability does not actually bound the
amount of information the algorithm
reveals about X and thus doesn't prevent
overfitting in these interactive
settings so they provably prevent
overfitting and non interactive settings
but not in these interactive settings
and and one example is the one I just
showed you so what we need is something
stronger which I call distributional
stability and let me just introduce this
notion called distribution sorry called
differential privacy which is one such
definition this was due to work McSherry
nice Eamonn Smith sort of very exciting
for a number of reasons but what it
basically says is that if you have two
data sets X and X prime that are close
let's say they differ on a small number
of their entries then the probability
distributions ax and ax prime should
also be close in a particular metric so
for differential privacy that metric
says for any event oh the probability of
that event under the two data sets
should be close by this multiplicative
factor and the small at a defector but
that's not really what's important here
what's really important is just that
this is some distributional stability
notion which says that the algorithm a
of X should have a close distribution
over outputs to a of X prime where
closed is measured in some way that
depends on the definition so I'm just
going to write epsilon Delta there to
sort of evoke the fact that there's a
couple parameters but there are many
such definitions so in fact there's a
growing family of notions that are that
are useful in the space and the key idea
is that when you have this type of
stability guarantee the sort of
distributional stability then the
algorithm
reveals little about the input X in a
precise sense and what that means is
that if some person comes along and runs
some algorithm a of X they learn very
little about X and then if they interact
with the data set again they run some
other procedure that now depends on a of
X it can't over fit too badly to X and
this is a concept we can formalize in a
number of ways and Thomas will give more
details on how you formalize this type
of concept I'm just going to give a high
level proof overview and one thing I
want to point out is that this
definition often requires for any
non-trivial guarantee that this
algorithm a be randomized so often the
best algorithms we have satisfying these
properties in the best ways we can
prevent overfitting and interactive
settings involve randomized algorithms a
so choosing a randomized algorithm
around the data so I have about ten
minutes left so I want to give just like
a very very kind of high-level
introduction to what this buys you and
then I will defer more of the details to
Thomas so let me just give like a quick
framework so that I can actually make
some statements that are a little more
precise than what I've said so far so in
this model we have a population P it's
over some domain you don't really worry
about what the domain is and we have an
iid sample x1 through xn drawn from that
population and we have some class of
statistics Q that were interested in
estimating and we're interested in
estimating Q on P so for example we
might want to know something like just
you know what fraction of P satisfies
some property Q this is called a
statistical query but you can ask for
lots of different functions of P and
what we want to do is we want to design
some estimator a that gets sort of holds
in its mouth the data set X drawn from
the population and a should allow some
kind of data analyst some user to give
it a query Q and it should give back an
answer a an a should somehow be close to
the true answer Q of P which usually
just means close as real numbers like it
just means you know within say 1%
it can depend on what exactly Q is
asking for and of course the challenge
is that a doesn't observe PA only has
access to its sample and so it needs to
do something clever to prevent
overfitting
to prevent giving answers that are close
to Q of X but far from Q of P and in the
setting of course we want to consider
interactive data analysis we don't just
want to have one query Q and get one
answer a we want to allow some user to
issue a sequence of queries q1 through
QK and we're going to allow those
queries to depend on the entire
transcript of what's come before so
we're not really going to make
assumptions about what this kind of
analyst or user is doing we would like
to basically treat this analyst as
something we don't understand it just
gives us query as we give it answers and
we want to kind of design one estimator
that works well no matter what the
analyst is trying to do okay and of
course you could try making more
assumptions and then maybe prove more
but but sort of in this line of work
we've mostly been interested in what you
can do in a very general model so let me
give you just one class of queries that
people have looked at a lot these are
called statistical queries so the query
is specified by some bounded function on
the space of samples and you just want
to know the expected value of that
function on a random sample from the
population and you'd like that answer to
be within alpha so the answer lives in
negative one to one so there's some
small alpha that you're interested in
getting the answer to within those are
very simple but it's actually a highly
like general highly useful family of
queries it captures things like means
variances covariances scores of a
classifier so in particular all of the
kind of questions we asked in the
Freedmen's paradox example or
statistical queries it can implement
gradient descent vitaly can tell you way
more about what you can do in the
statistical queries model so i want to
show you basically how we can get better
accuracy for statistical queries we can
do it for a more general family of
queries but I just want to talk about
statistical queries so we already saw
kind of an example of what
can go wrong if you use the naive
estimator which just treats X as if it
were P and answers the query using X so
just estimate the statistical query as
if X were the real distribution so we
already saw what can go wrong
so what we saw is that if you're
allowing someone to ask K queries then
the error of those queries can be about
square root K over square root n so in
the previous example the number of
queries was basically D plus 1 and we
got error square root D over square root
N and that was just a special instance
of statistical queries and by using the
scores on the data set we were just
using this empirical estimator so I said
that we want some way of answering these
queries that is stable distributionally
stable and I said that there's this
connection to privacy so if you wanted
to answer these questions in a
privacy-preserving way one of the
simplest things you can do is just add
independent Gaussian noise to the
empirical estimates so just add zero
mean Gaussian noise with some standard
deviation Sigma that will kind of set
later and what we can show so this comes
from a paper of mine with rice Vasily
and you seem Thomas Janke Adam Smith and
Murray stemmer and also builds on
earlier work by six other people is that
this estimator actually has better
accuracy so if you set this noise
parameter correctly then the accuracy
improves to the fourth root of K over
square root of n so we get sort of a
kind of quadratic improvement in the
dependence on the number of queries and
this is kind of like surprising right I
mean I think this is something that just
sounds sort of like it goes over kind of
quickly but there's something cool here
which is that by adding noise we can
reduce the error so by adding noise in
this particular way we improve the
stability and even though we're giving
answers that are less accurate for the
data set they're more accurate for the
population so I think that's interesting
so let me give just like the very simple
overview of how you would try to
such a statement Thomas will I promise
say much more about it so the first
thing that you basically need to
establish is that the noisy answers
satisfy this distributional stability
property so if you think about an
algorithm that basically takes the data
set kind of runs the analyst in its head
and outputs the entire sequence of
queries and answers this is a stable
algorithm and you can show this using
kind of ideas from privacy or various
information theoretic measures roughly
the idea is that changing one sample in
the data set can only change this
average by a small amount and adding
noise adding Gaussian noise kind of
smoothes out those small changes that's
a very very high level intuition of why
this is stable in the strong sense that
we need and the more interesting claim
is how we use stability so the way that
you actually use stability is we prove
something of the following form so we
say suppose you have some stable
algorithm M I want to call it m to
indicate that it's not a if some stable
algorithm m and what M does is it takes
a data set and it outputs a query it
selects some query from the family of
queries you're interested in like a
statistical query and now you look at
the query it selects applied to the data
set and the same query that it looks
that it's selected but applied to the
population
well if M X you know didn't look at the
data these would be very close by
standard kind of sampling guarantees
like a Chernoff bound or central limit
theorem argument but what you can show
is that if M is stable then even though
the query itself depends on X these two
quantities will be very close to one
another with high probability so
intuitively what distributional
stability buys you that kind of output
stability doesn't buy you is that no
distributionally stable algorithm can
output a query for which the data set
and the population are different even
though we know such queries exist you
know unless you draw an enormous number
of samples there will be queries
for which X and P diverge but a stable
algorithm can't choose one so I think
with my last like two minutes I'm just
gonna give you kind of why this is true
I'll prove sort of a weaker theorem
which doesn't prove that this is true
with high probability but just in
expectation although at the level I'm
going to go through the details it
doesn't really matter much so the idea
is to consider two distributions that
we're gonna relate to one another so the
first is the following you choose a
random record and a random sample in the
data set one of the end samples and so
you choose I and then you choose that
sample so X I the ith sample and then
you look at the query selected by the
algorithm M of X so this is like three
kind of correlated random variables the
other is you choose a random I but you
just choose an independent random sample
from P independent of the data set and
then you take the query Q that was
selected by M of X so there are two
different two distributions and notice
that this expectation here is just some
function applied to this distribution
and this expectation here is some
function applied to this distribution
and we can relate the distributions
using stability so the first step is to
say that if I start with the blue
distribution I can change it to a new
distribution where instead of using X I
take the sample and X and I replace it
with a fresh independent sample Z and
distributional stability says that these
two distributions are closed these two
joint distributions have to be close
then we can just sort of play with
symmetry here so here I have X I which
is now independent of what MCS and Z and
so what I can do is I can just flip
these by symmetry ik and say well let me
just put X I into m and let me pull Z
out this is exactly the orange
distribution so there's a little kind of
two-step
outline of how you prove that stable
algorithms cannot output queries that
distinguish the data set X from the
population P so thing up so this is kind
of the the main theorem this is kind of
the the first thing you can do with this
is you can show that there's a stable
estimator that gives better accuracy for
interactive statistical queries than
this naive estimator better meaning that
we would play that we replace the square
root K dependence with a fourth root K
dependence and it has this kind of nice
take-home that adding random noise to
the answers can actually improve the
stability and reduce the overall error
you can extend this to other types of
queries I'm not gonna say much about
that also we have lots more powerful
differentially private algorithms and in
certain regimes of perimeters you can
actually say much stronger things so if
you have data from a set of bounded
dimensions the domain has bounded
dimension then you can actually answer
like exponentially many queries you can
recover sort of a logarithmic dependence
on K the number of queries that you
would get in the non interactive setting
but with some dependence on D that's
kind of unpleasant and you can also show
that this dependence on D is kind of
inherent so when you have a high
dimensional data set when you actually
have a data set D a data set X where the
dimension is bigger than the number of
queries then you can't really hope for
for anything anything much better than
than this polynomial dependence on the
number of queries another result we can
show is that if you do have a modestly
high dimensional data set so Adam it did
the dimension of the data is much
smaller than the number of queries then
there are significant computational gaps
in the worst case so there's some kind
of malicious analyst strategy that
involves some kind of cryptography that
will kind of force any accurate
estimator to overfit very badly even
though we know that there are
inefficient estimators that would do
better so unfortunately I don't have too
much time to go into these results but
they're based on some interesting
cryptographic constructions called
fingerprinting codes
they think are sort of surprisingly
connected to this area and the last
thing I wanted to do is I wanted to
mention another very nice results of
dork at all in which they consider a
setting where we bound the number of
rounds of queries so you allow maybe a
huge number of queries but there's you
know some big batch of non interactive
queries then another big batch of non
interactive queries and the number of
rounds is small and what they show is
that you can basically replace a
polynomial dependence on the number of
queries with the polynomial dependence
on the number of rounds and only a
logarithmic dependence on the ambient
number of queries and they have some
sort of very nice application to what
they call reusable holdout sets so it's
a very nice line of work and
unfortunately I won't have much time to
talk about and so I will just I'll just
kind of wrap up there that's the high
level kind of overview of the model and
what we're trying to do and I'll just
say thanks and let Thomas give more
information about the specifics
[Applause]
it's a regime where kids mention bigger
than one over square root n so so the
question is in this regime where in this
regime where K is much much bigger than
D can you get anything with square root
one over square root n and the answer is
we don't really know of anything so so I
mean basically this is the best I could
get in that regime if I want what if you
insist on 1 over root n so it's a very
nice question square root B over n no no
because the number of queries very large
so if you wanted say if I mean if you
have say if you have like exponential
and D for example then you could could
then you'd be ok because then you'd have
like convergence and statistical
distance or something it's a it's a very
nice question so something I've thought
about it seems kind of challenging but
okay thank you
[Applause]